so my my olympic coach  told me after a particularly challenging  workout where i could not hit my splits  before going to the rio olympics that  that was okay it was the rule of thirds  and he was an olympian so i was you know  i always soaked in everything he said  and i was like what's what's the rule of  thirds and he said when you're chasing a  dream or doing anything hard you're  meant to feel good a third of the time  okay a third of the time and crappy a  third of the time and if the ratio is  roughly in that range then you're doing  fine so today was the crappy day along  your dream chasing right and if the  ratio is off like you feel too good all  the time or too bad then you you've got  to look at if you're fatiguing or  or not trying hard enough or pushing  yourself